[Music]
gas flares from a tower above the flood
a few kilometers away dozens of vehicles
carrying fuel food and life-saving
medicines are stranded as highways and
bridges are damaged
by Elsa one of Nigeria's leading oil
producing states is cut off
devastating floods have hit nearly one
and a half million people everybody is
affected either directly or indirectly
everybody is affected so it's a disaster
of monumental
Monumental Dimensions where we are cut
off from civilization we are cut off
from everything yeah
as victims flock to camps concern is
rising about shortages the displaced
speak of inadequate food rations
major streets have become waterways
Wooden Boats ply streets instead of cars
and as conditions worsen health concerns
rise
these images scare health workers and
victims alike sick people in camps and
the potential for a health emergency
officials say the water in Bayelsa state
may not be safe for drinking as its
sauces have been contaminated that means
there could be outbreak of diseases in
Days to Come As farmers are unable to
stock because of damage to roads and
bridges
the federal authorities say they have
played their part with Promises of more
Aid
we have deployed hundreds of trucks of
relief items food and non-food items
to this affected areas in fact to the
whole country in all the states of the
Federation including the federal capital
service
as flood devastated this all-producing
state concerns rise about Nigeria's
output and the safety of all
installations
we make sure that they are adequately
protected because we have stepped up our
operations and we have heightened
security
an assurance that will be welcomed by a
jittery energy Market but for victims of
disease disaster what would convert them
more is finding shelter and food to feed
the hungry so far they say they haven't
gotten enough
foreign